inception is a film that's stuck with
many fans
since it's released 10 years ago the
haunting final shot of the movie has had
people debating back and forth over
whether cobb was dreaming or not
and it's become a massive talking point
in the film theory community
however there may be an even deeper
element of the entire movie that many
have missed
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down all of the evidence
that hinter cobb being the job
there's several lines laced throughout
the film that suggests his friends and
family
are trying to get him to let go of the
idea of his late wife which has held him
back from being with his children
now from here on out it's heavy spoilers
ahead so if you've been living in a
dream world and haven't had a chance to
check out the movie
then i highly recommend that you check
out now if you're still here
huge thank you for clicking the video
i'm your host definition
now let's get into our inception fan
theory
so since its inception inception has
inceptioned
inceptions what what i mean by that is
the movie is a multi-layered mission
into the mind of a man's
subconsciousness
based around the notion that an idea can
be a dangerous thing
this is something i've experienced
myself and since re-watching the film
for
a big breakdown on the channel the
reality of
what could be going on has been gnawing
away at me every night
now in the film we follow cobb an expert
at stealing ideas
who's been apparently hand-picked to
break into a newly appointed ceo's mind
in order to convince them to split their
company apart
cobb succeeds in doing so and as a thank
you
saito the owner of the aforementioned
corporation's competitor
pulls some strings at the american
border so that cobb can pass through it
and be reunited with his children
cobb hasn't seen them for years and as
we learn he's consumed by guilt and
regret
believing that he caused his wife and
their mother's death
in the film we discovered that the two
spent decades in their subconsciousness
and during this cobb planted the idea in
her mind that their reality was wrong
this helped in getting her to wake up
however this idea continued on far past
the dream
and mal cobb's wife became obsessed with
the notion that they were still in a
dream world
and thus she committed suicide in order
to wake up
miles staged the scene to look like cobb
had been complicit in her death
and thus he fled the authorities cobb
just can't get over her though
and throughout the movie she ruins his
plans shows up at the wrong moment
and almost traps him in the layers of
his own subconsciousness
however at the end of the movie he
finally lets her go
and reunites with his family it seems
like he came to this decision on his own
but what if this itself was an inception
what if letting her go was the entire
point of the film
and his friends staged the mission so
that he believed he'd come up with the
idea himself
well there are several clues that point
towards this
now we learn that inception has to
pretty much be
inspired you can't just tell someone to
have the idea to subscribe to your
channel
as they'll be able to trace us back and
what you should do
is provide content that makes them want
to stick around
now when we see the crew carrying out
inception in fish's mind
they do this by reinforcing the idea of
his father
so that when he reaches the final layer
it all comes together to plant one idea
in his mind
though fisher believes he's decided to
do this himself he's actually been
manipulated into it
through the repetition of certain things
now this
is very similar to how the layers work
with cobb firstly
is the big song that plays throughout
the movie genre
this french tune is dropped in at
several points in order to signal to the
team that a kick is about to happen
and that they're running out of time on
the surface
it's a fun little song but it actually
holds
a lot of meaning behind it now firstly
the song is about someone letting go
of all the regrets that they have in
their life they're moving on to
something else
and if being played to cop throughout
the movie at several key points
could be subliminally telling him that
he needs to move on from mal
i really can't think of any other real
reason that this song was picked above
any other songs as all it does is
provide a signal to the team
so they could have used this or never
going gonna give you up by rick astley
if they wanted to
but the fact that they stick with the
french one shows its importance
mal herself is french as well so the
idea of letting go of your regret
being sung in the same nationality that
your regret centers around does hammer
this home
you also see early on a picture by
francis bacon
and this was actually one that the
artist created after the death of his
lover
and the wolf face on it symbolizes that
he was unable to fully recreate his lost
love in all their glory
this mirrors how the male a cobb created
in his mind is a mere shadow to the real
one
and this painting could have been placed
to subtly hint this idea to cobb
another big moment is a line that miles
says in the film
as when visiting he says to cobb come
back to reality
at the time it's pretty much just a
throwaway sentence
but it could be reinforcing this notion
that cob needs to come back
we see a similar tactic used in the film
at one point when at the start of a
dream it's hindered officiate that his
father wanted him to be his own man
similar to the miles moment this is a
throwaway line
but it's dropped to that when fischer
gets deeper into the dream
it hammers at home in his head hell even
the scene of cobb saying goodbye to his
wife
is similar to the one of fisher saying
goodbye to his father
both of them must let go and fish's
father dies similar to how mal does upon
cobb confronting her
in addition to this the random numbers
that fisher gives is a safe code at one
point in the film
is actually reused at several points it
appears as the woman's phone number in
the hotel
and also as the hotel rooms that the
group stay in
the number is then used by fisher
himself as the safe code
and thus it was planted into his mind by
his random outburst
which was later reinforced by the group
so we can see that one throwaway line
uttered and a seemingly meaningless
moment
can be built upon the further into the
dream you go cobb at one point is told
that he's not one to judge people
living in a dream world and this too
could further the point in his mind that
he needs to wake up
and let go of what's holding him back
cobb does seem to exist in a reality
that's very much like a dream and he's
chased by a strange agency which acts
similar to how projections do in
someone's subconscious
now before i talk about these in more
detail i need to talk about saito
saito is arguably the person that
actually adds to the theory of cobb
having to let go the most now firstly
the line
do you want to be an old man filled with
regret waiting to die
is said three times throughout the movie
similar to the three-layer dream
this forces cobb to question whether he
wants to live the rest of his life
filled with regret
alone and away from his family or if he
wants to go back to them
if he holds on to the idea of mal he
definitely will end up like that
and he'll be forever fleeing from this
strange agency
now we never learn who these are but
they could be working for saito to
convince him that he needs to find
safety and to trust him saito even shows
up to save him during this chase scene
which seems completely out the blue yet
the more we think about it
the more we know that saito was watching
him as he would have to be stalking him
in order to show up here saito also
takes away one of cobb's allies early on
in the film
and though he seems like a threatening
figure if this theory is true
then saito moving this man merely made
him think that he should do the job with
him
i think the old man filled with regret
line is very similar to the line about
coming back to reality
and at the end of the movie in which
cobb comes face to face with saito
this could be a revelation of that here
he sits opposite an old
lonely man and cobb literally sees his
own fate laid out for him
reminding him of what to do now this
happens after his conversation with mal
but it's still needed in order for him
to fully wake up
cobb really has two choices and he could
either remain in the dream world
or take a leap of faith like they agreed
to in order to return to the real world
the escaping of the dream juxtaposes
what mal wanted
which was to pull him further into it
now an interesting line in the final
conversation that the two have is
is that mal says you promised we'd grow
all together and cobb says
that the two actually did in their
shared dream this is one of his wedding
promises to her
and it may also be the truth that cobb
once knew but had forgotten
we're also told in the film that a
positive idea works better than a
negative one
and this too may be the reason why cobb
shutting down mal
feels like such a win saito also touches
cobb's totem
which we learn pretty much invalidates
it doing this could be saito
deliberately letting kob know that
dreams don't matter anymore
and that he should leave it behind and
lastly
lastly is the fact that cobb gets
through customs at all
i don't know if you've been to america
but not a nice time going through them
customs now if this guy
was really wanted for murder i'm not
sure there's any strings that could be
pulled in order to get him back into the
country without being arrested
i actually believe that cobb merely
thought that he was wanted
and that the entire time he just told
people he was so that he wouldn't have
to face the truth
he had just built malub as an excuse as
he couldn't look his children in the eye
because he knew that he'd cause the
death of their mother this is why he
constantly looks away whenever the
projections of them try and look at him
and he's been running because he just
can't face up to the reality of the
situation
he finally gets through customs but
nothing was really done
and in the country the police won't be
looking for him probably because they
never were
so in conclusion cobb is told through
music
his friends family and peers to let go
of mal
aka his regrets otherwise he'll be an
old man
waiting to die alone on the job he
believes that he's the one who let go of
mal
and returns to his family however when
we look at it for what it really is
the true inception was putting the idea
in his head that he should return to
them
something that he could only do after
leaving his regrets behind
and that's the video now hopefully i did
my own inception here
and made you agree with me but if you
don't or if you do
leave your comments below as as i'm sure
there's a lot to talk about
if you want to watch a full breakdown on
the film that points out all of the
cool little easter eggs and awesome
things in it then make sure you check it
out after this
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
you